there are a number of factors that have
gone into the neverending carousel of
Spider Man actors and Tom Holland
shouldn't get too comfortable in his red
spandex to find out why that is take a
look at the real reason we've had three
actors play spider-man in ten years
superhero movies dominate the current
Hollywood landscape but that hasn't
always been the case though some may
point to 2002 x-men or even 1998 blade
as the start of modern comic book movie
mayhem the superhero boom owes a lot to
2002 spider-man its box office take
towered over the other Marvel movies
taking in 821 million dollars worldwide
that's a number that would be impressive
even for a film released today nearly
two decades later it's more than
Deadpool 2 made in 2018 in the days
before the Dark Knight in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe spider-man was the
biggest thing going in superhero movies
directed by Sam Raimi and starring Tobey
Maguire the 2000s trilogy of spider-man
spider-man 2 and spider-man 3 kept the
genre thriving while it was still in its
relative infancy with a combined total
of nearly 2.5 billion dollars at the box
office the movies arguably defined
McGuire's career and the second film is
still considered one of the greatest
superhero movies ever made and yet
despite the trilogy's enormous success
and undeniable impact on the film
industry the franchise was rebooted just
five years after spider-man 3 if you're
just looking at the numbers spider-man 3
was a monumental success it was 2007 s
highest grossing film domestically and
he made more money at the box office
than either of its predecessors in fact
it's eight hundred ninety million dollar
worldwide total remained the best
box-office performance of any spider-man
movie until it was finally topped in
2019 by spider-man far from home so why
after making a ton of money did
spider-man 3 sound the death knell for
McGwire and Raimi's iteration of the
character well to put it simply the
movie had some problems generally
speaking you'll have to look long and
hard to find a hardcore fan of
spider-man 3 critics were not kind to
the film and many fans didn't like it
either the plot was overstuffed with
three villains The Sandman Harry
Osborn's new Goblin and Topher Grace is
Eddie Brock who only becomes venom in
the final third of the movie there was
also a love triangle with the addition
of friends Stacy a retcon of Uncle Ben's
death and Peter
Parker's own inner battle after he's
infected with the Venom symbiote which
manifest as a series of infamous dance
numbers in the ensuing years since the
film's release even the people behind
spider-man 3 have joined fans and
critics and dragging the movie with
director Sam Raimi saying the film was
awful in a 2015 interview my son told
the world at his guy I have a 9 year old
daughter loved spider-man who she's
supposed to looked up to now in spite of
spider-man threes well-documented issues
the immediate plan from Sony was to
continue the franchise with the current
team attacked after all the movie made a
boatload of money and in Hollywood
that's what counts
Raimi began working on spider-man 4
shortly after he wrapped the third film
with both Maguire and Kirsten Dunst
ready to return the director was looking
to feature the vulture as the film's
villain and had even secured John
Malkovich for the role he also nabbed
Anne Hathaway to play antihero and
Felicia Hardy black cat in the comics
but in the movies she would have become
the Volt hrus the film even had a
scheduled release date of May 6 2011
alas it never came to be the issue was
that Raimi while working with various
co-writers was unable to get the script
to a place that satisfied him he was
desperate not to repeat the mistakes he
made in spider-man 3 once the director
realized there was no way he would be
able to meet Sony's deadline for the
film's release date however he told the
studio that he no longer wanted to make
the film rather than trying to find a
new director to take over what Raimi had
been working on Sony decided to restart
the franchise from scratch even before
Raimi quit working on spider-man horror
Sony already had a contingency plan in
place for a reboot on the day in 2010
when Sony announced the cancellation of
spider-man for the studio also announced
that a new spider-man would arrive in
theaters in 2012 the decision to reboot
rather than continue with the new
director came from the studio's belief
that Peter Parker's story was best told
through the lens of a boy becoming a man
specifically a spider-man the reboot
would take Peter Parker back to high
school and for this the studio settled
on Andrew Garfield yes it's real nice my
weakness its small knives just well
eight years younger than Maguire
Garfield was still at least a decade
older than the character he would be
portrayed and was actually two years
older than Maguire was in the first
spider-man film in spite of Garfield's
advanced age director Marc Webb
he was best for the role in the Amazing
Spiderman for a number of reasons
including his chemistry with co-star
Emma Stone who was playing Spidey's
doomed love interest went Stacy with the
rebooted Amazing Spiderman hitting
theaters just five years after
spider-man three many fans were
skeptical about how well the film would
be received as it turns out they should
have been the film underperformed on
nearly every level one heavy criticism
was the film's decision to retell
spider-man's full origin story almost
beat four beats as it had been in Rama's
film only a decade later by spending
much of the running time on a story that
the audience already knew the movie
wasted its chance to do something new
and exciting perhaps ironically
criticism was also leveled at what the
film actually did try to do differently
rather than being an awkward nerd
Garfield's Peter Parker was depicted as
being a cool teen skateboarder who
disrespects Authority and has no problem
standing up to an even bullying Flash
Thompson it just didn't feel or act like
Parker too many fans changes to the
story were also criticized a new
plotline was added that made the death
of Peters parents part of some kind of
vague conspiracy and it helped drive
Peter's motivations he still had the
traditional driving tragedy of Uncle
Ben's death however raising the question
of how many dead father figures one
story really needs before it all gets
too convoluted the amazing spider-man
might have underperformed at the box
office and failed to excite fans but it
wasn't a bomb by any means sure it made
less than any other spider film to date
but that's still plenty of money and
work quickly began on a sequel the
amazing spider-man 2 brought in Oscar
winner Jamie Fox's new bill and electro
but the filmmakers didn't stop there
seemingly determined to ignore the
lessons learned by the overstuffed
spider-man 3 the film also added a new
Green Goblin along with a tattooed Paul
Giamatti as rhino performing cinema
history's least convincing Russian
accent
perhaps the biggest mistake made by the
film was the decision to kill Gwen Stacy
while the 1973 comic book story of her
death is considered a classic the plot
point of a woman dying to motivate a
male character was considered tired
offensive and damaging by the time the
film was released in 2014
there was also a strong sense at Gwen's
death was not earned in the film and
that it was done simply because death is
what fans associate with the character
combine all of that with some subpar
performances and it led to both the
worst critical reception and the lowest
box-office take of any spider-man movie
up to that point
while the spider-man franchise was
floundering the Marvel Cinematic
Universe was flourishing after Ironman
kicked off the MCU in 2008 and
especially following the monumental
success of 2012's The Avengers the
franchise redefined what audiences
wanted out of superhero movies to put it
bluntly fans expected superhero movies
to be good and movie studios expected
them to make the kind of money that few
other franchises ever had with film
starring b-list heroes like guardians of
the galaxy earning more money at the
box-office than amazing spider-man 2 the
MCU is becoming too big for Sony to
ignore on the other side of the coin
Marvel was also desperate to bring
spider-man into the fold their films
were undeniably successful but that
success was built on the backs of
traditionally lesser loved characters
like Iron Man spider-man on the other
hand has been the face of Marvel Comics
since 1963 the belief was that
spider-man belonged in the MCU with the
rest of his Marvel brethren where the
character could lead the next generation
of Marvel films to an even higher level
of success and when major studios are
motivated to make a deal sometimes the
impossible becomes possible cash money
for a picture of spider-man he doesn't
want to be famous and I'll make him
infamous after the performance and the
amazing spider-man 2 Sony decided to
pursue another reboot and got Marvel
Studios to produce the third iteration
of spider-man in a decade in February
2015
Disney and Sony reached a practically
unheard of deal to effectively share a
franchise Marvel Studios would produce
new spider-man films alongside Sony and
also include MCU characters in
spider-man films but Sony would get full
distribution rights for the movies
including all of their box office
earnings
in exchange Disney got permission to use
spider-man in their own films such as
The Avengers movies and all of the
merchandising rights to the character
now with Ball Studios wanting what's
best for Spidey it was time for a third
Peter Parker to suit up
with Marvel Studios onboard it was
decided that Spiderman would debut not
in his own reboot film but rather as
part of a huge ensemble in 2016 s
Captain America Civil War that would
remove the pressure of carrying a solo
film from the new Spidey
and ease him into the larger MCU without
having to cover the origin story again
Marvel also decided that the new Peter
Parker would once again be a high
schooler this time unlike Maguire and
Garfield who were both pushing 30 when
they were cast in the role the studio
cast an actual teenager for the part 19
year old British actor Tom Holland
Holland's version of the character
debuted in civil war to rave reviews
while there is a subtle mention of a
tragedy in his past viewers met a Peter
Parker who was already fighting crime as
spider-man fans and critics alike loved
Holland's personality in the role while
also finding it refreshing that he was
actually for the first time in Spidey's
history close in age to the character he
was playing two years after his pitch
perfect MCU intro and Civil War Holland
starred in his first solo film for Sony
spider-man homecoming the movie was the
first spider-man film to be produced by
Marvel Studios and it proved to be a
massive critical and financial success
Colin followed up that goodwill by
appearing in the two largest Marvel
movies to date 2018 s Avengers infinity
war and 2019 s Avengers endgame
I'm Peter by the way Doctor Strange I
made up names um
I'm spider-man then both movies have
already become cultural touchstones and
they rank as the fifth and first
highest-grossing films of all time
respectively furthermore spider-man's
contributions to each film helped raise
the characters profile not only in the
MCU but to the movie going public as
well when the next spider-man movie
debuted less than 10 weeks after end
games premiere it did so on a wave of
MCU driven excitement and anticipation
the movie obliterated the previous box
office record for a spider-man movie by
becoming the first film in the franchise
to gross 1 billion dollars at the
worldwide box office despite the runaway
success Holland has enjoyed his
spider-man there have been rumors that
Sony is looking to regain full control
franchise after all they have their own
budding universe made up of other Spidey
characters in which spider-man himself
is not legally allowed to appear Sony
had tremendous success with 2018 s venom
as the movie earned nearly as much at
the box office as spider-man homecoming
the studio has already greenlit a sequel
as well as Morbius based on the living
vampire who first appeared in spider-man
comics with Jared Leto and the starring
role eventually Sony's going to want
spider-man to appear in these films to
boost their profile and if Marvel isn't
willing to let Hollen do so then Sony
may just go ahead with a fourth reboot
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stop or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]